John I think it's incredible in your
acting career you played these really
powerful figures from Star Wars the
Pacific Rim coming up and then you're
thrown into 1960s Detroit with this sort
of role weird you're kind of powerless
in a lot of ways yeah wasn't like for
you it was the struggle it certain parts
because normally you know you know when
I play a person I'm I'm able to fight
back you know but this is this is
different and this is reality space in a
true story but it requires an approach
of you know just being integral one and
be respectful because I'm playing a real
person
I'm curious as actors when you first
heard about this the Detroit riots in
the houses Motel incident I learned from
it from the script honestly and that's
what stimulated my wanting to know more
and do my own research and look up
everything and the fact that you know
I've been through so many black history
months growing up as a kid you know went
to Howard University we never learned
about the Detroit riots you don't talk
about this to anyone ever
I understand it you know we'll it feels
like people might hate you
let me see this movie or hate your
character I'm curious as an actor when
you when you get a script and you look
at it and you can tell there's gonna be
this vile reaction to the person you're
gonna play does it give you pause I
would be I think confused and slightly
worried if anyone empathize with my
character you know my character very
much represents these sort of epitome of
bad policing racially motivated police
work and he is very much a racist and so
I totally understand if people hate my
character and I think it's I think it's
important that they they do feel you
know
anger or any kind of negative reaction
towards him and you know that was the
responsibility I had was to represent
that you know without kind of I think
pulling any punches but like both of you
when I'm watching this film and I'm
watching you you seemed so
panic-stricken that is it just reaches
through to the audience how did you get
yourself into the place into that place
on set I was thinking about this today
the fact that the set was so calm it was
it was easy for me to get to those
really heavy places when it was like
chill and when we weren't you know
shooting I've never been through
anything like that
I've been harassed by police I've been
talked to a certain way about police
I've never been in that extreme
situation so for me it was hard to do
myself and the only way I could do that
was taking myself to dark places
thinking about family members which is
stuff that I hate to do but I was just
trying to get to the point where I felt
Larry really was in this room to me it's
really like a conversation piece I think
it makes you when you leaving to pick up
the phone and call somebody or tweet say
something yeah what's that conversation
you want folks that I just hope that the
conversation is is had in the context of
moving forward how to heal what to do
because those answers are very
complicated and it's hard for anyone to
just think of thinking up
I need you to survive the night
you